to tell the story of a family you have
to truly build a family and since day
one the way this cast is bonded together
in such a such a beautiful way makes me
so incredibly proud and thankful
[Music]
i start off every casting discussion
with the biggest shout out
to the greatest of all time
vicky thomas legendary casting director
who helped us sift through
hundreds and she must have seen
thousands
of tapes this is the era of kovid and
she's the one who first turned us on to
to jabari banks these women are so
special to me because so special
because they're the women who discovered
me gave me this beautiful opportunity to
be with these beautiful people with this
beautiful family and i can't thank them
enough so i'm sitting on my friend's
couch mind you i'm couch surfing i got
the call back right
and i saw the call back date and it was
on my birthday and i was like wow yeah i
know this i might have footage of this
we brought a little mustache at the time
he had this little like kind of little
grubby mustache or whatever and
so we're talking in the lobby of this
hotel and i'm like man this gets special
like his five his energy his swagger his
charisma he looked you in the eye you
know that's important to me you know i
always felt that in will and this
character what i look for
he embodied all of those things and the
energy we stepped outside and i very
quickly took some photos i'm like i want
to get a feel for this guy in front of
my camera from my lens 20 minutes later
i walked away really thinking myself
like i think we found him we did the
callback right i finished the scene and
he's like hey yo jay um this is gonna be
kind of off the wall and i was like okay
what do you want me to do i'll do it i
mean i was like i don't care what it is
i'll do it he's like yo do me a favor
run to the bathroom if we can just shave
that mustache yeah i don't mind give me
like
give me like
a minute so i did that came back baby
face i knew it was him straight up it
was that simple i'm in my friend's
closet and i got the lighting right
and and i get on the call
and uh there's will
i'm stuck yo what up philly yo and i'm
like what's up what's up i'm like this
is crazy what's up man what's up yo
from the deepest parts of my heart i
want to say congratulations to you
uh you have the role of will on bel-air
[Music]
i'm ready i'm so ready after that call
like i just went to sleep
[Music]
every single day every single thing that
happened led up to here right now
calling action on the very first shot of
a pilot that we wrote
[Music]
right away on that first take you know
just seeing his confidence seeing his
natural foundation as an actor he's such
a deep well i knew after that first take
he's ready for this after we wrap that
first scene i was like okay okay okay
okay i'm getting i'm getting the hang of
this i think i think i can do this i
know i can do this once you're there
doing it surrounded by all the energy
it's so real
your
be here day one mama blessed day one
shooting in bel air we're in west philly
out here
literally
the most
incredible natural talent i've ever
worked with i've worked with a lot
thankful this guy special thank you man
we're just beginning you know it's day
one this is just the start you know we
always talk about the craft growing in
the craft
you know what i mean yes sir just
speaking i'm really proud of you bro yo
i'm fulfilled
glad you're safe we'll talk later
yeah everybody's just been
so welcoming and warm and it's just a
very comfortable environment we're gonna
we're gonna do some good work today it's
gonna be fun i'm adrian holmes and i
play phillip banks on bel air adrian is
the perfect reimagined phil came to bel
air for a better education simple
i instantly connected with the material
i thought it was so well written
starting off with the trailer that
morgan put together when i watched that
i just thought this is brilliant this is
genius it's such a very smart concept
there's so many parallels between you
know will and me and james avery and
adrian this is my first job and that was
will's first job and the discovery of
that and and the curiosity of it all is
really important to me and i for sure
think it was important to will at the
time i'm always usually the younger guy
on the set you know but then i was like
wait i'm i'm the patriarch i'm the
anchor i'm the i'm the daddy-o uncle
phil you know he's a father a husband an
uncle a brother he's america's uncle
this is like a tribute to james avery
for me being able to give back and just
show respect and it's like an honor to
be in these shoes
i'm playing on film
that's me oh that's crazy i have a
message from my manager saying please
give me a call and i remember i started
shaking because i was like why would he
be calling i kept talking it's like
calmed out i get him on the phone and my
manager's voice was so
high and shrieking i was like what is
there an emergency he was like
i felt a
huge
weight
of
what is the culture
going to think and i really just don't
want to let the culture down
i really appreciate morgan saying let's
bust the doors off of what we think of
is and by the scripts that i've read
what i really feel now is we don't
really know who aunt viv is she's
actually much more vivacious
sexy took
months to get this together thoughtful
and of course we know she's warm and
graceful yo cassie is crazy i love her i
love her you know she her energy off
camera is so
wow but it's you know it's so beautiful
to have cass just has this unique
ability it's like attributes like she's
like a moment creator like she just
knows how to create these really
beautiful unique moments on screen you
know with her swag and just she's just
such a professional is my husband making
money tonight that's really what's on
outfits why
oh tim how you been working with ali and
seeing his take on carlton and what he's
brought to that character he not only
realized the vision in terms of the
reimagined carlton but enhanced the
material audiences really get a chance
to kind of see inside his psyche and see
inside how his mind works it has a lot
to do with his inability to see his own
successes him being overwhelmed with his
own failures his constant comparison to
his own father every single person
that's ever had a dream can identify
with
chasing something and never feeling like
you're good enough he's the original
just prince of bel air and i think will
smith's character comes in as fresh
prince if you want to do well just keep
your head down and follow my lead whoa
whoa carlton and will there's so many
differences they clash and they butt
heads because they have different
upbringings and different ideas about
the world he's like the star of the team
um there's no parent i am just the star
of the team so to be able to learn how
to coexist with one another definitely
takes them a while to get i hope uh one
day we can talk about why you're really
here
ashley she is a very smart confident
girl you know she's wise beyond her
years she knows a lot and she's the baby
of the family is there any acting advice
that you can give to me because this is
my first gig okay um i would say be
natural and
have fun
be natural and have fun
honestly i want some advice
so far i gotta say you think so yeah
okay
this little sweet blossom is growing
into this woman and exploring new parts
of herself and the world and and what's
beautiful is that viv is here for all of
that expansion every time she's on
screen it's just it's just magical
let's go find you something fit for a
friend
knowing hillary now i see why
morgan on my most humble tip i see why
morgan
likes what i bring to hillary he just
brings so much swag and flavor to the
role of hillary and like i remember in
her auditions like literally you know
two lines into the audition we all knew
hillary is a lot like me in that she's
very headstrong she's very determined
she's in like this unconventional career
but like she doesn't let it faze her but
she has moments where like the
situations really try to knock her off
her strategy knock her off of her truest
self when i got cast for this um
everyone was like oh my god so cool like
i'm so proud of you but how was coco
jones and i was like coco jones like i
know as much as you know and it's that
she's still that [ __ ] like she's always
been that [ __ ] and she's still that
[ __ ]
so
i think she could smell the fan on me
when we first met so i think we're like
now we're becoming friends
when you're watching fresh prince the
reruns at on nick at night over and over
again you're like damn i want to be lisa
like i wish i could be lisa she's so
cool she's so bummed she's got will
she's got everything you know what i
mean and so this i say that all the time
it's like a dream that i didn't even
know that could happen joseph marcel
i've grown up watching him since i was
you know a teenager 12 11 you know about
eight years ago on a bbc drama i played
his son
when i got this role i had his number
and i
i called him and i was like hey hey
joseph uh it's stimurakambola do you
still remember me is that jimmy i know
congratulations
we're all very excited for you the
emotion that this iconic legendary actor
is saying these words to me and i feel
so honored to take on sort of his
character do something different with it
every set that you work on is not as
gracious as this i'm very thankful
seriously and blessed to like be able to
really get a chance to know
not just the character but the people
and that also just shows on screen this
time we're trying to make you forget
who you are
and where you came from
[Applause]
don't let it do that
what you could not predict
is the chemistry of how all of these
cast members have come together they
just have boundless energy and that kind
of gives boundless energy to uh veterans
like us everyone is passionate about
this project and wants it to win i love
how talented everybody is i'm like wait
a minute as soon as there's a beat like
we start singing and dancing and it
looks the hell good
i come to set so excited to see everyone
every day this is a collaborative medium
television is so collaborative we are
nothing without every single crew member
and every single cast member and just
being reminded of that that we are just
one piece of a much larger machine
i don't know it makes me makes me feel
good that's why casting is so important
right you want people where it doesn't
feel like an uphill battle every take
they understood what needed to be done
with this reimagined vision and that's
just a testament to the collaboration
and their willingness to really trust
the vision and give all they have to
their performance is take after
[Music]
you